une cuisine flambant neuve au centre
Alfred de viinny pour mieux accueillir
les futurs élèves de l'atelier cuisine
c'est l'une des nouveautés de la rentrée
du centre de loisir vcinois qui compte
2000 adhérents bah on était un peu serré
à l'étroit on pouvait plus circuler et
c'est vrai que la communication
entre participant aux ateliers était
très difficile on va travailler les
produits de saison ça c'est assz
important les épis tout ce qui est goût
saveur et cetera et on va faire un tour
de France de toutes les cuisines que
l'on a régional et aussi européenne et
mondiale s'il le faut j'aime beaucoup
cuisiner et puis je connais le chef déjà
j'ai choisi l'option une fois par mois
c'est-à-dire qu'on on a des cours le
matin et puis après on partage le repas
on mange tous ensemble voilà j'ai choisi
cette option là et puis on fait ben un
peu de tout de la cuisine
régionale cette année le Centre propose
51 activités contre 47 l'an passé parmi
les nouveautés peinturees chinoise champ
prénatal et plus inattendu dans un lieu
dédié au loisirs un atelier
d'accompagnement pour trouver un emploi
c'est l'association Solidarité nouvelle
face au chômage qui intervient ici au
centre donc c'est un peu atypique dans
un centre culturel ça permet de d'avoir
un accueil supplémentaire de tout ce qui
existe aussi actuellement pareil des
bénévol qui aident qui soutiennent c'est
un coaching prochaine occasion pour
rencontrer les professeurs et s'inscrire
le forum des associations de Voisins le
bretonneux qui se tiendra le 8 septembre
au gymnase des pyramides